[Music]
you want to be a normal teenager I got
news for you you're not normal Doris
who's
Doris uh I
am do you think this is the right place
for him you say that about any place my
brother's dying he hasn't talked in
years I'm so sorry my wife passed away
my dad died when I was three Christ it
ain't
competitions I think I should start
sleeping at Sun Co so your doesn't get
too lonely he's my child when he's in
pain I'm in pain I'm your child too what
about God sake give me a break you can
come to my house if you need a place a
party my mom won't be there and you can
do whatever you want oh my God I I have
to tell everybody um but who who are
you everyone says this neighborhood is
scary but like when you're in it it's
like not that
scary thank
you it's really hard taking care of sick
people sometimes you need a
break I dare need to kiss
D he could have died and you weren't
here once your brother's gone he's
gone and you will miss taken care of him
you miss everything all the good all the
bad we're going to have fun again you
and
me I'll learn how to be fun again
Doris old lady's name it was my
grandma's name oh she died the day I was
born my God is there any conversation
with you that is not like thoroughly
depressing
[Music]
me